こんにちははじめそうです皆様特技というものありますでしょ
僕肇社長はとくにありません
いや本当にないんですあのなんか色んな人いるじゃないですか
歌を歌える輸注バーナーアップができる輸注バー
音を出せる輸注バーガー大抵の人で何か者の豚時があるんですけどもあの私に関しては
本当に特技がゼロですしいて言うならば好きぐらいスポットがそういうのってよっぽど
だけないダメじゃないですか何かそんなんか
部活になるんでたそのなんだろ2書でしたね誰しもは1個持ってるそのアレみたいな
感じなんですけどももっと特殊な特技スペシャルスキル特技というものが僕
ないと思ってたんですけどもいろんな人が話してるうちにあれこれ
俺だけなんだねみたいなものをついに見つけてしまいました
今日はそれを皆さんに紹介しようと思いますそれはな
に彼そうポケットモンスターの bgm をすごい病脳にインプットされているという
ことでございます
特になんだよねこれ島国なんだよねちょっとわからないんですけどゲームの音出てくる
アレ特定のポケモンとの戦闘とか野生のポケモンとの戦闘の音楽でトレーナーとの戦い
自分で言ったチャンピオン視点の返答系の bgm とかをほとんど何か覚えてるん
ですなぜか否かこれ友達とかにたまにやらせるんですよ適当量だけ流して釣って流す
程度とか当てると結構な確率で惹かれるんです
っていうことはたぶんみんなあんまり覚えてないということなのでこれ島部品なんじゃ
ないかなと思って今日ちょっと実際にいろんなポケモンのゲームの音楽を流して
いただいて瞬時にそれが何の音楽家っていうのを当てようと思います答えられなかっ
たらちゃんと答えられないって言うんであのヤラセだして本当に行ってみようと思い
ますでライガーっ
それで越冬審判も健介とキョロ指名しますよろしくおねがいしまーヤラセじゃないよね
ヤラセじゃないですよホントに大丈夫ねほんとに一致で賞はからちょっと変わって快適
なヤラセじゃありませんってこれヤラセじゃねまぁこれマジわかったら作者っていう
感じで
うんいやちょじゃあ私近所するんですよ
同中の初めてなんでジャッジとりあえず片っ端のポケモンのゲームの音楽の bgm
お腹いろいろ世出してもらいました
僕は一切見ておりません今から聞いた音楽を
分かった瞬間干すんでもうちょっと見てくださいそこであってよと思い
ではよろしくお願いしますよろしくお願いしますそれでは第一大しますはい
配布雑誌安全カーをおおおおっ
これはわかりやすくてな気泡が入ると彼らの犬の遠吠えの形が大丈夫
お願いします
はい
あれですスーパーチェーン期間です
すごい黒いにあるセンサー分かりません太公望とか始めたぶー
ドンジョン
[音楽]
me
早いえっとねぇあの園てない今スイクンなのはわかるんですけどどれかなんですよね
まあ
お前的ですかはい
それからいきます korres ハートゴールドソウルシルバーなんですよ
お願いします
[音楽]
はいすいくんですねぜっやばいくれた become the key ねー
ハートゴールドそれぞれ話君そうそうよゴアの来校はエレキギターっぽい感じで始まっ
てエンターもっとドスが効いてるんですよ
なんかドラム声ちいくんだけそういうちょっと綺麗な音が入るんですよ
はいえーとでルビーサファイヤのレジシリーズですね動く
先生たいです
是非はい
えっと3万の野生ですね
正解です難しいすっげぇマジであっ
[拍手]
[音楽]
いやーんアレンジ入ってるこの音楽
いや初代のやつなんだわかるんだよね分かりませんこれはポケットモンスター
ピカ v-
ガードいいわーぞ次行きましょ続いておきかわいいカム柄せん
[音楽]
[拍手]
ブラックホワイト2のちゃん秒の id 宣伝2ケーって全館別って呼ぼう
街で抜くあれだけねなんかチャンピオン設定
基本ちょっと怖いっていうかその挑戦的な音だけなんですけど
それをねじゃあ
スカレーだのはからですよ
スカル団の
幹部とが偉い方でしょ
正解ですすごい拙いで疲れたわかりやすいねうん
はいえーるだんのしたっぱすごい正解です
なぜマニーと手差し一緒だから難しいんですよねまぁちょっと聞けばわかるかな
ベベル月限も話してる次元が違うと思う
[音楽]
はいっ
とこれはファイアーレッドリーフグリーンの伝説のポケモンですねすごい
正解です安打早くリーダーミューズ道ですそうですそう
行く
[拍手]
[音楽]
えっレシラムとゼクロムんですね正解ですねほんとだけど
べしなんですよアーサーでどうぞよかったら
はい
えっとフロンティアブレーンはあってます
今回ブレーンのプラチナでしょ正解素材方なら大丈夫
[音楽]
半面なんだよたま
とねー
はぁっ
えっとねやったね clothes and with めっちゃいいんじゃなーい
でっの前節ポイント殺さない以下んんあっえっとそれがリーダーだとかそれに所
正解で処遇が路線へへっ無駄相撲ないよもうマジでエッグねー
[拍手]
オメガルビーアルファサファイアの知れませんでしょ
でっかい花火は気質に会いに行く前でやっちゃうん
すごいすごいすごいマジ
[音楽]
早レッドリーフグリーンの野生の来ても正解です
カッコイイマジでヤバイ
[拍手]
3年のえっと主ポケモンですね
違いもエースっぽいもんじゃないっ
別2のふつうの家生の3分のポケモン
なんかちょっと強い板
変な変換と車番
そんな感じ普通に参らせるポケモン住んでお願いします
ダイヤモンドパールのユクシーアグノムエムリット
part ゴールドの方ですね数時間ですね
えっブラック方はいっ
時間違うプラチナの
やぶれたせかいのギラティナ
正解ですおい g フォルムの切れてないんですよ
止めた世界のプラチナしかないんですねお願いします
[拍手]
[音楽]
わかるよグラボとさようならわかる
[拍手]
オメガルビーアルファサファイアのグラードンカイオーガ線正解ですあなただっ
[音楽]
セントーサないんだこれなんな台パンを何とかしていいでしょ多分寿してわかりません
ちょっと武器してはわかるのっちり興味やばい
ああ
はいえーとダイヤモンドパールの
橙もパールなんだよ
ステンノー
正解です2
[音楽]
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
えっとウルトラにクルーズまってってって
ゲージエッチっ
グッズ松尾これ
チェーンはてぃもしーですねうん
車の人たちの下っ端の音楽葬
正解でつくるなんですよまーすからなんだ
ああ
[拍手]
ダイヤモンドパールの野生の方でも正解です
ポケモンゴーの野生の不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不
野生のポケモンだね県立の政府ですね
えっと県立のジムリーダー戦正解ですはぁ
根津エルダー山町ですああそうですねつですねえっ
お前がご飯 how じゃない保証
how
how じゃないほうのライバル
世界にグラディオンアースおっしゃって
[拍手]
えっえっ
やっぱわかんなフレア団の日と違いますねぇこんなひとりだっけブルータルされる
ドラムんです
なになるわけです
ウルトラ彫塑たいですねか
ずっとの調査会がはずっと
ああああああ
[音楽]
ここらへんだながら俺に食べるのは
赤木正解です
n ですねこれ生活ですああ
病気シェイプですねこれ正解です
はい大ボスねうっううっ
ファイアレッドリーフグリーンのチャンピオンズに実家へでグリーンですねこれ
ああああああ
れっどすか
正解ですああ
白菜ですね閉会
[音楽]
えっとねー
ダイパの音楽
おおよそ正解ですどこですかこれは209番がわかりませんで道路覚えたらまずかっこ
いいよいいよ
道路覚えて
はいダイパのライバルの男の子前回ねあのこういう
から来てやって少数
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
ブラックホワイトの爪に出せですね絶対えっ
えっ
利根錦銀盤のジムにですね図1階です
まあえっ
まじかー全部一緒にしか聴こえからをやりなさい
ああ
[音楽]
ホップ正解です
[拍手]
金銀版の野生の鳥も双喜亭カイデー
犬だけのバトルタワー月滑っ
[音楽]
[拍手]
船なんだよなぁのと2にある船
オーフィス正解です捨てられ分市税られ船はわからん
[拍手]
別
台パンの伝説とか純連ぽいところ
正解です
ブービー以下あもう夏に新しい to do ちょっと purity で生じします
me
me あった